- There has been a revival of activism
among our young people,
and that's the most
encouraging thing to me.
Black Lives Matter means that there are
wider systemic issues that have produced
a culture of violence
within our community.
But it's all connected.
When you look at decades
of failed housing policies,
poor educational institutions,
chronic under-employment,
and unemployment, and poor health care,
and then you throw in drugs,
and then you throw in guns,
little wonder, you'll see this
culture of violence emerge.
And so, you have this
issue of the lack of trust
that the community has with the police,
and it's all connected with one another.
And so, what Black Lives
Matter means to me, is that
if we're going to have safer communities,
more peaceful communities,
and more vibrant communities,
we're gonna have to address
some of these larger
systemic issues.